Lauren bobert was kicked out of
Beetlejuice the musical uh the traveling
the thing about musicals is when they
um leave Broadway or even when they are
still on Broadway
but I think it's when they close but
maybe Beetlejuice is still open I don't
know it was like a national tour
yeah I was on one of those years ago for
Andy gate your gun when I was 11 and my
mother went with me for like three
months we toured around the country and
then you know in the real Annie Get Your
Gun on Broadway the Gina Davis was the
star she was a movie star and she played
Annie Oakley and then we had this woman
who's like this Ethel Merman
impersonator
uh
and she was you know the touring version
of the musical often it's a far fall you
know what I mean on Broadway a musical
have like Josh Groban and then when it
goes on tour around the country it'll be
like Joey Fatone like it's uh it's a
apocalyptic
fall in terms of the cast but
they didn't deserve this whatever she
was doing she got kicked out of
Beetlejuice the musical
for causing a disturbance
she was in the theater I think vaping
talking
they cited incident report and obtained
which representatives of the Buell
Theater in downtown Denver say a group
of people were asked to leave after
vaping singing recording causing a
disturbance well they were getting into
it she's a hillbilly
you gotta let her get into it a little
bit she's a hillbilly
you know that's the thing I don't really
want to defend her here but she is a
hillbilly and there is a culture they
have and some of it is kind of singing
along and vaping and stomping their feet
and doing like ham bone and jug bands
and stuff I mean this isn't not a woman
who's like seeing shows at the West End
the West End of London or on Broadway I
mean she's a heck she's a straight up
hillbilly and I'm not saying that in a
disrespectful manner you know publicly
uh privately I am but I'm just saying
like
this is who she is that's her culture is
to kind of sing along and be a lad she's
a classless animal is what I mean like
so but you know I don't know was was she
being that disruptive I don't know I
wasn't in the theater
she probably was
but that's the thing she's unaware like
the only reason she's going to see any
type of theater is because it's
Beetlejuice
that's it the only shows that Lauren
bobert would ever go see are movies
she's seen before
uh you know she's never going to
she was she wasn't gonna go see like the
ferryman on Broadway the chess
Butterworth the brilliant Sam Mendes
thing that Gaffigan told me to see and I
saw three times it was amazing
she's not gonna go see Death of a
Salesman Lauren Boberg she's not going
to see A View From The Bridge
she's not gonna go see a Shakespeare in
the park she's not like oh Othello is
playing let's go see a fellow she wants
to see Beetlejuice she's a hillbilly I'm
not saying there's anything wrong with
Beetlejuice but there probably is I
haven't seen it I'm guessing
I'm sure it's fun
I'm sure it's fun and Goofy and silly
but that's the only theater
I almost side with her here
she's trying
like
she's trying she's a Waffle House
employee she's a bartender she's and and
don't hit me with the classes horseshit
of like
well she could still be brilliant she
ain't she ain't
yes you could you could work at
Applebee's and be a genius you could
you'd not most likely I'm guessing law
of averages
she's a goon
her and her husband beat the [__] out of
each other on their lawn the cops come
to the house uh
she's like Sarah Palin 3.0 she's getting
divorced because they can't stop beating
each other up they can't stop I don't
know
smashing the windows of each other's
cars out with [__] bats they find
around I mean they're like a fun couple
the sex is probably really fun because
then they attack each other with like
weapons you know you know that she's
been barricaded in the bathroom and then
she goes and talks about family values
and how important they are and you know
her kids are screaming and crying
and he's like I can open this door you
know there's been a moment in her house
where her kids are in their rooms
they're terrified they're they're locked
in their rooms they're terrified and
they're screaming and she's in the
bathroom and he's kicking the door and
he's like open this [__] door open
this [__] door make no mistake that's
her home life
that's her home life she's probably
thrown around and for good reason she's
probably gonna mouth on her
she's probably got a mouth on her and
for good reason she's probably thrown
around let's be honest
now let's be very honest now this is
very I often get into problems here on
this show because I just speak
extemporaneously but she's got a mouth
on and there's probably reason she gets
shoved in the kitchen there's she it's
not a out of nowhere shoving okay when
Lauren bobert trips going down the back
steps it's not for no reason she has a
toxic mouth and and I don't I am not and
I can't believe I have to say it's
amazing that I have any representation
in this town because occasionally I have
to say things like this I am not
defending hitting women but
Lauren bobert is not getting shoved
accidentally
she doesn't have to lock herself in the
bathroom accidentally she's not getting
chased when he chases her in a car when
her husband I think his name's Jason I
forget but when her husband gets in a
car and he chases her around
okay it's not by accident she's she's
she's a live wire
she's the problem
she insults him she probably talks [__]
about his dick
I'm guessing because she's not going for
like deep intellectual things but that
hurts me he can't say [__] about his
dick can't talk about Jason bobert's
dick is it Jason bobert yeah yes
so this woman who again had to leave her
house
because
of family values and she was getting
through our mouth
was getting her into she was her mouth
was as a as a black older woman would
say her mouth
um was writing checks that she couldn't
cash right because Jason was probably he
had had enough of her he'd had enough of
her and she's probably like I'm gonna
end up dead
I bet one day he looked at her and it
was like it was like full ojis like I'm
gonna cut your [__] head off and put
it on a bike and again not for nothing
not for no reason she was probably very
inappropriate and she said I'm gonna I'm
gonna die here I gotta go and she's just
trying to go to Beetlejuice because
she's a hillbilly
she's a hillbilly with a big mouth who
brings Whoopins on herself that she does
kind of deserve
and she's also in Congress
she's also in Cut let's not leave that
out she's the elected representative of
the state of Colorado whatever that
means whatever that means but I have no
interest in that I only look at a
character study she is a saucy sexy
bartender who knows how to [__]
she knows how to get on a dick and ride
it she can make a man come which is more
than I could say for some of these
squawking liberal Birds up in the
Northeast where all sex is death I'm
just saying I I'm not even having sex
with women I'm hearing it I'm hearing it
people talk to me they share things with
me so you get a little spicy hillbilly
like Lauren bobert who's been [__]
since she's 12. she is a she's a real
Southern uh Carnival [__] and in a good
way in a good way it makes a man hard
when a when a woman knows how to [__]
and will [__] she will suck a [__] she
will get on her knees and she will suck
a [__] and she doesn't care if you've
showered you don't need to shower she
likes a little spice she likes little
spice she can snap your eyes will roll
back in your head she knows how to [__]
but she's also got a mouth and she's
gonna get you in jail she's gonna get
you in jail those Northeastern cold
liberal women will plot to destruction
of your life for years and then they'll
take everything from you you won't even
know what happened they'll just end up
somewhere in a [__] Bungalow in
Florida and you'll be in some apartment
going what the [__] hop you won't even
know you won't even know but bobert it's
just it's she's she's a spicy Saucy
dangerous woman who will make you kill
her she will not stop until you kill her
that's the type of lady she is
she's gonna just say the wrong thing and
you're gonna want to kill her
and she's in Beetlejuice
just trying to have fun with her friends
her friends are also pure Isle white
trash garbage people
they have no education they have no
class they have no distinction but what
I will say about them they're probably
all decent Fox and they like drugs and
alcohol and you know what I don't mind
any of that I can't do it anymore but
they're not the hanging out with Lauren
bobert is not the least fun you will
have it is not the least fun you will
have
Lauren Boba because she's all like gay
marriage gotta go and there shouldn't be
no abortions and everybody in the Jews
are running around [__] with
everybody and the moral code but she'll
get on her knees and suck your [__]
after she's done a line off of it she's
an old school
[__] like you know bar Made From Dusk
Till Dawn get on the bar vampire core
and that's important